we've got some video here of Latino
people
latinx people as they call them in Texas
explaining why they're leaving the
Democratic party she wants the party to
take stronger action on issues like
abortion and voting rights but our poll
found that the top issues for Latinos
was actually the cost of living we see
that prices are through the roof and we
want to know what people are going to do
stronghold States like Texas signs of a
political shift among Latino voters with
more now leading Republican Maria
you
were a Democrat and you are now a
republican why because the the fact that
the Democratic party has changed a lot
and I didn't identify more with the
Republican party what things
well we're for God country family and
hard work
God country family and hard work pretty
good even if we all disagree on what the
exact definition of God is but that we
could all maybe agree that there's
something else going on and countries
pretty good and hard work is pretty good
meritocracy is good borders are good so
you're not going to believe this but
Latino people are like everybody else
and they care about the same things we
all do but that's why the media is
always trying to Latino people vote this
Ryan black people vote this way
please bring them up out this way
because if they can keep you in that box
you are not a fully functioning human
being you're just a cog in the machine
uh but here's a Latino NBC reporter
admitting the Dems are screwed Latinos
are the largest the fastest growing
group of boaters and the numbers are
there we Latino voters represent make up
about one out of 10 voters but
they're also very unhappy I mean the
pandemic hit them very hard the economy
is hitting them very hard inflation is
heating they are happy about the job
quality and if you see the the main
issues Latino care about yeah they are
right their economy the job quality so
yeah this is a concern and this can make
things very difficult for Democrats
yeah Latinos once again they're just
like
they're just like all of us you know
they care about jobs they didn't want to
be locked down all of that stuff they
actually want borders
once you see it guys you just see right
through it so either
this is for that little sliver right I'm
always talking about that sliver of
people that actually could shift right
because you got your your sort of base
on both sides you got your bass on the
right you got your bass on left but that
sliver of people that are the ones that
are still undecided or actually could
vote a different way or whatever it's
like this is what we have to illuminate
for them you can be part of the party of
racism and you can be part of the party
of high taxes and no borders and
chopping off children's genitals that's
a set of ideas that's you know you can
go for that or you could maybe be for
say hard work in the Constitution and
borders and then you know going hey I'm
gonna put myself out there and see what
happens because we have equality in this
country not Equity so a little bit of it
is on me so that I could do that uh what
was that thing that Pursuit of Happiness
thing right because they wrote that one
down too and that was pretty good